die [ __ ] heutzutage kriegen den mund
nicht zu voll das ist ein richtig ehren
sorge dafür das war so was in den
letzten tagen auf youtube ab gegen kurz
zusammengefasst wird bekommt hat ja
diesen einen song rausgehauen dicke
lippen die scheinbaren blasen vielen
dank für die information noch mal katja
das war was wir uns alle gefragt haben
im moment kleine rote und ganz ehrlich
wisst ihr was die zeit der reaction
videos ist zu diesem video auf jeden
fall jetzt vorbei heute wir haben so
krass wie directions gehabt dann
teilweise eine halbe stunde nachdem ihr
musikvideo online gehen schon reactions
da gehabt so da frage ich mich seid ihr
behindert deswegen leute heute keine
reaktion falls ihr das gesagt haben wir
schon heute wie im titel schon steht
ihnen die besten katja gasser wie
champions rein und gucken mal wie das
internet katja sofort das habe ich
letztes jahr schon bei diesem milch ist
gift ding gemacht zwar auch sehr lustig
habe ich auch gut gefallen deswegen noch
mal heute und wir legen los auf jeden
fall habe ich den besten katja mit
google kann auf der seite punkt nie also
quasi / kasseler da sollen die 25 besten
- zu katja seien es 1 2 und eines der
zwei besten teams angeblich der welt auf
dieser seite ist das kopf-an-kopf-rennen
bei der heutigen ghz snapdragon katja
gasser witze und lea braun 96 erzähle
ist das was meint ihr bei den ersten
platz holte wirklich einfach nur gute
leute habt ihr mich jemand so lachen sie
wie gerade eben in diesem moment leute
mir ist wirklich das gibt es aus der
fresse geflogen vor lachen auf jeden
fall platz 125 2 lustigsten bekannt dass
das finde ich scheiße aber zeigen sie
mir darauf nicht angewiesen leute denn
wir haben auch twitter und peter gefragt
was sind eure besten katja mir die
geschenke wir gehen jetzt durch mark was
ist das alter von gina vorstadt liebe
leute kurz umfang an der stelle könnt
hier oder hier mit uns abstimmen könnt
ihr nach diesem bild heute nacht noch
schlafen ich auf jeden fall nicht es ist
einfach so ein mops mit der gesichter da
wir hier von gucci ghana mit vier
männern geschlafen 3 das geht ja vorjahr
war ein ruhiges wochenende
was herr was für ruhiges wochenende ein
ruhiger nachmittag oder ist nicht bei
euch also ich finde drei partner für
die geschlechtliche interaktion die zur
reproduktion der menschlichen spezies
bestimmt sind und bei der der eine oder
andere kleine bastard der rasse homo
sapiens in sich dass auch in die röhre
geschoben werden kann das ist eine sache
die auf jeden fall mindestens dreimal
pro nachmittag stattfinden sollte das
ist böse leute ich sehe was was du nicht
siehst was denn gute hexe will ich
gemeinsam leute ihr habt ihr es
bitteschön schon mal gesehen hat ja
umgeschwenkt da unten rechts mehr sage
ich dazu nicht
das ist ein ice von kiel eine rose ist
offen
ich weiß ich habe mich ohne willst sagt
man heute dass zwei menschen die perfekt
zusammenpassen würde oder würden katja
krasavac und feind rennen ein gutes
fahrrad geben
wenn fahrenschon mit sowas zitiert
worden ich zitiere aber in verbindung
gebracht wird dann wären jedoch das
perfekte paar weil ich glaube van bergen
war auch die juristin der lage die fünf
mal in geschlechtliche interaktionen
morgens mittags abends und nachts also
20 mal am tag auch zu liefern wie das
nächste ist michael punkt excel nicht
gehören
konzentriert du kannst bastian ich hab
dir schon mal kräftig aber ja ja nein
lassen wir das nächste stamina von
henrietta ich bin herr wie katja des
duos das ist einfach rosada und katja
daneben aber leute ich muss jetzt das
beichten ich weiß das klingt gewagt aber
das ist nicht zum ersten mal dass ich
diesen gedanken habe es gibt ein paar
youtuber rinnen möchte ich an der stelle
mal sagen da drängt sich schon das eine
oder andere pokémon auf das eine oder
andere pokémon ist aber nicht das ein
oder andere pokémon sondern ist groß
aber es gibt wirklich original so viele
menschen die aussehen wie ross an einem
echten leben gut die laufen nicht so
nicht die gegend aber würde ich machen
ich würde erstmal auf die werfen die
[ __ ] heutzutage kriegen den mund nie
zu folgen das ist auch richtig ehre
aller vor allen dingen die linke sieht
aus als würde sich als ich kenne die
linke natürlich nicht habt ihr noch nie
in irgendeiner form von video produktion
auf der einen oder anderen plattform zu
augen bekommen einmal kommen dass ich
aus dass sie einfach eiskalt aus wenn
beide kurzen gerade die linke ok
selbstlos ich weiß dass über sie bereits
gelder aber dazu wer kennt sich man
macht mal wieder einen mädelsabend steht
mit seiner besten freundin und ehe man
sich versehen hat hat man 20 bockwürste
in der presse haben wir hier noch eine
einsendung von ida dazu muss jetzt sagen
leute kann ich jetzt nicht ganz genau
verstehen würde aber so oder so sagen
dass 21 cm als körpergröße für den
partner vielleicht doch ein bisschen
kurz ist von anna-lena sinotrans ich
fühle mich mittlerweile richtig dumme
leute auch an der stelle habe ich nicht
so wirklich ahnung was das jetzt genau
bedeuten sollte was ich sagen kann ist
dass katja auf dem oberen bild definitiv
nicht so gut getroffen ist
[Musik]
ob das schon okay man jetzt natürlich
fällt jetzt voll und versuche dabei
nicht an das vorspiel zu denken
ich habe euch jedoch eine folge was das
geht verlegt da gibt's mehr videos von
mir in diesem sinne leute hätten die
kunden bis zum nächsten video